[Musica]
gratitudine è emozione sono i sentimenti
che voglio condividere con voi in questo
nostro incontro
soprattutto
richiamare in questa immagine mitologica
della fenice vivere con voi l'esperienza
della fenice la fenice si pone tanti
interrogativi risorgerà davvero lo farà
se ha deposto le sue ceneri in un posto
sicuro e ben circoscritto latte la
fenice e soprattutto messaggio di
tenacia per tutti noi e la tenacia e
quello di che abbiamo bisogno tutti in
questo momento forse sempre nella vita
ma in questo momento in modo particolare
voglio dire in questa città in modo
particolare quindi grazie per questo
evento
io ho attraversato molte strade sono
stata fortunata ho avuto occasione di
scegliere di svoltare quando la strada
mi offriva una svolta
l'ho l'ho presa quella svolta e quindi
il mio messaggio è svoltiamo quando c'è
una strada che ci propone risultare ho
iniziato a studiare giurisprudenza
nell'università di bari
sentivo che il diritto non era la mia
materia avevo segretamente deciso di
scappare di casa per studiare sociologia
ma non l'avrei mai fatto e poi mente
sulla mia strada è comparso un
professore maestro il professore di
diritto del lavoro seguendo il suo corso
ho capito che il diritto aveva degli
agganci con la realtà ed ero soddisfatta
non dovevo più scappare per studiare
sociologia un professore maestro ha
segnato la mia prima svolta un
professore che ha destato curiosità
rispetto e soprattutto ha saputo
insegnarmi a scegliere
un'altra svolta
questa però viene dopo
l'altra svolta è stata la mia un viaggio
negli stati uniti
strade da percorrere le svolte da
imboccare
perché una borsa di studio che una
fondazione americana mi ha assegnato per
saggiare negli stati uniti prevedeva un
viaggio per nave
il viaggio come momento di decantazione
per la paura che non posso nascondere
avevano nell'intraprendere
quest'avventura
è un viaggio verso il nuovo mondo
il nuovo mondo quante volte aveva
ascoltato la sinfonia dal nuovo mondo di
svolgere con mio padre e in quel viaggio
ho capito che la scelta la facevo io ma
la mia famiglia mi aveva concesso di
farla perché mi aveva lasciato andare
ancora un'altra svolta
torno dagli stati uniti e per vicende
varia della vita mi trasferisco in
toscana la terra toscana mi accoglie con
molta generosità diventa la mia nuova
casa accademica ma soprattutto la
toscana è la terra e le due figlie e qui
c'è la rinascita della donna nella
nascita delle figlie è un privilegio
quello della scoperta e l'incanto
irresistibile dell'amore genitoriale
un'altra rinascita e la rinascita del
diritto e questa rinascita io la posso
vivere perché
riesco ad avere una lunga parentesi
fuori dall'università italiana con
incarico di insegnamento presso
l'istituto universitario
quel logo che vedete in azzurro è
l'istituto universitario europeo di
fiesole
una rinascita del diritto perché diritto
europeo ci insegna a riina vite a
rispettare le culture giuridiche diverse
di tutti gli stati membri dell'unione e
dunque non è una felipe europea quella
che mi accompagna si è una fenice
europea che mi fa capire il motto che
dagli anni 2000 descrive l'unione
europea unita nella diversità le
diversità dei singoli stati membri sono
apprezzate sono valorizzate e tuttavia
devono essere composte in una unione
il cammino continua nell'istituto
università europeo ho dovuto anche
liberare tante paure e aprire la mia
mente ascoltare lingue diverse gli
studenti giovani ricercatori venivano da
tutti i paesi europei anche da fuori
dell'europa e quindi il mio orizzonte
doveva allargarsi dovevo superare
qualunque paura di comunicare con loro e
quindi ho capito che dovevo includerli
nella ricerca istituto di primeggiare
europeo mi ha consentito di svolgere
progetti di ricerca con un impianto
intergenerazionale un'esperienza che
forse l'università italiana dovrebbe
favorire ancora di più includere i
giovani studiosi nei progetti di ricerca
dei professori più anziani
ma l'istituto europeo mi ha insegnato
che dovevo costruire un'affidabilità
quegli studenti che venivano da tutto il
mondo dovevano fidarsi di me e io dovevo
dare loro un senso di profonda
comprensione delle motivazioni che li
avevano spinti fuori dai loro paesi a
studiare a fiesole
dunque affidabilità ma anche coerenza
coerenza del messaggio che dovevo
porgere loro nonostante loro fossero
come ho già detto così diversi
provenivano da paesi tanto diversi con
studi alle spalle molto diversi e dunque
la flessibilità nell'adeguare mi alle
loro esigenze e alle loro aspettative
e allora ho capito che c'è sempre
qualcosa che noi dobbiamo
imparare crediamo di sapere tutto ma
forse potremmo accorgerci che qualcuno
sa qualcosa più di noi dobbiamo
riformulare le nostre convinzioni
e forse sappiamo sempre qualcosa che
altri non sanno hanno scelto questa
frase di un teologo gesuita del seicento
un aforisma che è stato ripubblicato di
recente
un uomo che ha viaggiato in tutta europa
è diventato molto potente nei suoi anni
che ci dice è bene essere
intelligenti ma non saccenti l'eccessivo
argomentare e
cavillosità meglio un buon giudizio di
sostanza erano
argomentare più del dovuto
lo sguardo del diritto è la fenice che
mi accompagna qui più che una svolta c'è
una salita e mi accorgo che devono
misurare il passo devo saper misurare il
respiro nel novembre del 2014 sono stata
eletta dal parlamento in seduta comune
giudice della corte costituzionale
mi aspetta la corte costituzionale il
palazzo della consulta in piazza del
quirinale
cosa vuol dire per un giurista a
diventare giudice costituzionale
io sono ancora incredula ancora non
credo che quella votazione in parlamento
ci sia stata e che il consenso sia
confluito sul mio nome
in effetti è una procedura molto
complessa quella delle elezioni dei
giudici costituzionali
perché occorrono maggioranza molto alta
dei due terzi nelle prime tre sedute e
dei tre quinti dalla terza seduta in poi
quei tre quinti non possono mai scendere
al di sotto
perché c'è una maggioranza così elevata
e perché i parlamentari chiamati ad
eleggere i giudici costituzionali devono
creare fra di loro questa trasversalità
del consenso
la trasversalità del consenso e un
segnale per il giudice che viene letto
di totale indipendenza da qualunque
forza politica che ha contribuito alle
leggi quindi la trasversalità del
consenso si trasferisce in una grande
responsabilità di chi viene eletto
perché nessuna forza politica deve
essere rappresentata nella corte
costituzionale ma l'indipendenza e
l'elemento più forte della autorevolezza
di questa istituzione
io sono una dei cinque giudici eletti
dal parlamento ma altri 5 giudici sono
nominati dal presidente della repubblica
altri 5 giudici in tutto sono 15 giudici
costituzionali
provengono dalle cosiddette alte
giurisdizioni dalla corte di cassazione
dal consiglio di stato ed alla corte dei
conti quindi sono eletti dai loro pari
mi fa piacere
menzionare che solo recentemente la
corte di cassazione ha eletto la prima
donna nel colletto della corte
costituzionale
allora c'è ancora una volta una
trasversalità di provenienze in questo
collegio ci sono esperienze diverse
ciascuno di noi viene quindi da una
disciplina o da una professione diversa
ma proprio questo ci spinge a far
confluire le nostre competenze dentro
un'espressione collegiale una
deliberazione collegiale e la
collegialità è la grande risorsa di
tutte le corti ma devo dire in
particolare della corte costituzionale
questa differenza di provenienza non
vuol dire che non ci si possa non ci si
debba conoscere ed incontrare io penso
che non dimenticherò mai il momento in
cui per la prima volta sono entrata
nella camera di consiglio che peraltro
stupenda stanza affrescata nel palazzo
della consulta e quelli che sarebbero
stati i miei compagni di viaggio mi
hanno salutato e mi hanno detto di
scegliermi mio post è fatto sentire
accolta e mi sono detta loro saranno i
miei compagni di viaggio ma ferrato
anche i miei interlocutori e forse
saranno i contraddittori gli effetti è
così non si va sempre d'accordo le
decisioni possono essere all'unanimità e
questo è un grande elemento di
soddisfazione raggiungere costruire il
consenso fra 15 così diversi ma se così
non fosse si decide a maggioranza
votando con un alzata di mano la
maggioranza è comunque una decisione
democratica all'interno di un collegio
in italia non esiste l'opinione
dissenziente che esiste in altri paesi
che consiste nel riconoscere al giudice
che non è d'accordo
il diritto di scrivere a parte una
motivazione questo in italia non c'è e
per questo è molto forte lo sforzo del
consenso della costruzione del consenso
indipendenza
condivisione autonomia dalla politica
ascolto
ascolto è davvero un esercizio da non
dimenticare mai io credo che sia da non
dimenticare mai nella nostra vita comune
nella mia esperienza di giudice
costituzionale l'ascolto mi porta a
valorizzare la condivisione di qualunque
momento
le sentenze sono normalmente redatte da
un giudice relatore
assegnare un caso giudice relatore che
poi firmerà la sentenza la sua firma è a
fianco a quella del presidente significa
dare trasparenza a questa esercizio
deliberativo un giudice incaricato di
istruire il caso
redigere poi questa bozza di sentenza e
pensate che queste sentenze stampate su
carta vengono portate in una camera di
consiglio che normalmente si tiene a
settimane alterne di lunedì e vengono
lette ad alta voce dal giudice relatore
in una parentesi assolutamente non
tecnologica di questi tempi mi piace
richiamare a voi questa esperienza in
cui dopo aver letto il giudice relatore
raccoglie le indicazioni di correzione
degli altri colleghi possono essere
indicazioni molto sostanziose che
riguardano il merito è talvolta si deve
ritornare su alcuni passaggi della
motivazione la motivazione il cuore
della sentenza
dall altra si tratta magari di piccoli
rilievi stilisti addirittura di come
misurare meglio l'uso della
punteggiatura cioè una grande
discussione anche sulla punteggiatura
perché non è importante ecco io in
questa esperienza che ho fatto
correggendo ad alta voce la mia prima
sentenza non dimenticherò mai la mia
prima sentenza il mio primo caso ho
riscoperto il fumo delle matite appena
temperate che forse non usavo da tempo
mi sono fatte a matita e ho riscoperto
il gusto della gomma per cancellare
queste briciole che l'anno e con un
gesto che avevo di stato della mano e si
scostano dal foglio per procedere in
questa correzione ecco anche questo è
ascolto ascolto condivisione
in un collegio che deve essere unito
deve essere capace di trasmettere
messaggi forti alla società che fuori
questo è un collegio che deve sempre
tenere dritte le antenne per cogliere le
novità che ci sono fuori nella società
fuori da quelle camere di consiglio in
cui si decide o dalla camera di udienza
in cui si ascoltano le parti deve
cogliere le antenne deve cogliere con le
sue antenne i cosiddetti nuovi diritti
delle percepire i cambiamenti della
società
ma come decidere la corte costituzionale
ecco uno dei
criteri o se volete delle tecniche più
frequenti e la tecnica del bilanciamento
si deve assolutamente saper bilanciare
quando un piatto della bilancia va giù
deve essere riportato su per fare questo
un interesse contrapposto all'altro deve
essere parzialmente
ridimensionato la tecnica del
bilanciamento una tecnica delicata che
spesso si affianca la tecnica della
ragionevolezza
ragionevolezza e dinamismo nella
decisione ma significa la corte deve
fermarsi un passo prima di occupare lo
spazio che non è suo e cioè lo spazio
del parlamento
la discrezionalità del parlamento e del
legislatore non fa parte del compito che
deve svolgere una corte costituzionale i
giudici delle leggi come si suol dire
cioè il giudice che valuta la conformità
a costituzione delle leggi
bilanciamento ragionevolezza ma
l'equilibrio di genere rileva in un
collegio come quello della corte
costituzionale
io sono sempre molto cauta quando
affronto questi temi anche se ho
combattuto le mie battaglie come donna e
per me il primo elemento di un collegio
che deve conoscere un equilibrio di
genere è l'elemento della competenza
l'altro elemento che gli piace rimarcare
e non voglio dire che sia solo una dote
femminile è l'elemento della pacatezza
la donna può introdurre un elemento di
pacatezza e una discussione che può
essere anche molto accesa ma non è detto
può darsi che la donna sia meno pacata
degli altri ma la donna può essere
flessibile o diciamo che la flessibilità
e un risultato dell'essere il collegio
equilibrato nel genere o comunque nel
collegio si ascoltano voci anche
dell'altro sesso femminile
ma pensate a quanto è forte l'ironia se
l'ironia non è forse uno strumento
meraviglioso quando è
utilizzato dalla donna perché può
diventare addirittura
accattivante allora questo è un discorso
sulla resistenza è un discorso sulla
resistenza dove io ho imparato anche in
un collegio
difficile non nasconde la difficoltà che
ha avuto le prime volte che ho preso la
parola che si deve tirare fuori la
propria voce se si sta combattendo una
battaglia
giusta che si deve allontanare la paura
se si persegue un obiettivo di libertà e
molto spesso è questo che la corte
costituzionale si può fare tutelare il
pd e garantire le libertà
bilanciare diritti e libertà e si deve
quindi pensare a questa resistenza la
resistenza del cuore e la resistenza
della fenice che vigila sui vostri
risvegli e se la strada è salita come ho
detto prima genoa misurare il respiro
bisogna misurare il passo il mio è un
messaggio soprattutto alle persone più
giovani non soltanto alle donne se posso
dire in particolare alle donne
intraprende una carriera come quella che
ho avuto la fortuna di condurre fino
alla corte costituzionale di saper
scegliere di scegliere sempre tutte le
volte che c'è da scegliere e di imparare
e rinascere con questa fenice che vigila
sempre sui nostri risvegli grazie